emergency workers are carrying out
critical rescue missions across a large
portion of central america
heavy rains from the remnants of
hurricane ada have caused widespread
flooding and mudslides
the north coast of honduras has been
especially hard hit
here flooded roads and collapsed bridges
have made it difficult for rescuers to
reach those
stranded by the flood waters this is the
first time something like this happens
but everything is flooded over there
everything is flooded
on tuesday ada slammed into the
nicaraguan coast
as a powerful category 4 hurricane
despite being downgraded to a tropical
storm
the slow-moving system has continued to
drop torrential rains across nicaragua
honduras and guatemala it's the worst
natural disaster to hit this region in
more than 20 years
on thursday honduran officials issued
evacuation orders
warning citizens to move quickly as
weather conditions continued to worsen
this amount of water falling on the
mountains gives us the space of two
hours
maybe a little more but let's not give
it any longer let's keep two hours in
mind to be able to evacuate to protect
people's lives
in cities like la lima people waited
through flooded streets many desperately
seeking help for their families trapped
by the rising water
no no help has arrived we've been
calling 911 since this morning for them
to come
for the firefighters to come but no one
has shown up
authorities in guatemala say torrential
rains and mudslides have already claimed
several lives
to make matters worse weather
forecasters say ada could regain
force in the coming days as it now heads
on a predicted path
toward cuba and the florida peninsula
manuel rapalo al jazeera